this show is brought to you by meundies
go to meundies.com jooy rightow to get
20% off of your first order and free
shipping in the US and Canada and you
can save up to $8 a pair when you do the
meundies subscription plan that's
meundies.com
joeey show is also brought to you by
tracker never lose anything again with
tracker go to the tracker.com that's th
H tracker.com and enter promo code
church and you're going to save up to 30
you're going to save 30% off of your
entire order that's th tracker.com th
tracker.com and enter promo code Church
to save 30% off of your entire
order the show is also brought to you by
Club W go to clubw right now and go to
Club w.com Joey and our listeners are
getting $20 off of your first order
that's clubw
docomo and we know you hate paying for
shipping so Club W will pay for your
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more to Club w.com Joey and go to h.com
church to get 10% off on all of the
great optimization products like alpab
brain strong bone shroom Tech immune and
shroom Tech
sport oh
[__] it's
starting kick that [__] mu Le I want
to hear that in my [__] cans come on
kick that [__]
thing he's one of these deaf young kids
you know he likes music Low Crank that
[__]
horse there you go don't look at me
crank it to the top there you
go can you believe that it goes this
loud after for 2 minutes You'll Play it
like the [__] hemophiliac or
something
Jesus [__] Christ po stop being a
victim you [__]
[__] get out
there it's the Church of What's
Happening
Now Tuesday June
21st one of my most hated people in the
world was born this day what are you
going to do I hate this [__]
day
this [__] Jam this whole side I'm bad
motor F it's just it's [__]
classicus
Christ
[Music]
Jesus what's the story you bad
[__] Uncle Joey here leis Sayad
here Tuesday June 21st we're coming in
Tuesday cuz I got a big [__] day
tomorrow I got things to do people to
see people to see as you know it's been
hot in a [__] here I mean you
know and listen it's these [__]
Gentiles that make it hot I mean it
ain't that [__] hot but I tell you
yesterday there were some moments you
could not sit outside listen I love
being outside I love the sun I don't I
hate that indoor [__] [__] you you're
depressed get vitamin D vitamin D is the
best [__] thing in the world for you
a couple minutes in the sun I know but
Joey son cancer you know it's cancer
sitting inside four [__] walls
breathing the same [__] oxygen okay
that's [__] cancer you go outside you
sit under a tree you get close to the
[__] Roots it's making chlorophyll
you whatever the [__] you suck by that
tree you do some Dr bises you get the
little vitamin D you things change I
[__] changeed whole days with 10 15
minutes in vitamin D It's [__]
amazing how people actually scared of a
little bit of [__] sunlight I I you
know I get get up in the morning first
thing I do is walk on the balcony I want
to see what the [__] cracking I got to
get some air I want to breathe whatever
the [__] out there you see what
happened night before was windy you know
something were you ever self-conscious
about taking your shirt off cuz I always
used to be and there's a huge difference
for me between being outside and being
outside with your shirt off what do you
mean who needs to go outside with their
shirt on I'm talking just go outside and
get air and get oxygen right away you
want to be [__] tosing nobody want
nobody was talking about the beach I'm
not saying like who gives a [__] about
the beach I'm not even talking about the
beach you're just saying random walk
yeah to beaches a car to the beach no
that's drama I'm talking about you're in
your [__] house you get up at 600 you
know you feed the cats you clean the
letter box you take a shower you have
some coffee and about 20 25 minutes in
whatever the [__] time it is you open
your door and you go outside you go
outside and you see what the [__]
going on you already showered what are
you going to sit in that [__] house
for you go outside and you breathe and
you drink some water outside you you
give thanks to God for giving another
[__] day every day since I was
[__] in a rocket ship I always went
outside the house you got to go
outside I'm I don't think I'm
agoraphobic like scared of going
Outdoors [__] yeah you are you you sit
in that [__] house for three days it
gives me anxiety leaving like you get
anxiety I have no there's everything I
like is in my house I know that nothing
bad is really going to happen like I'll
drive myself nuts SP 3 hours trying to
figure out what to eat it's not that I'm
not saying going to a strip club no I'm
just saying walking in front of your
[__] house yeah under a tree getting
a little bit of sun breathing no music
no iPod no nothing just collecting your
thoughts for 10 minutes outside I don't
care how hot it is or how rainy it is
even when it's rainy I sit outside
sometimes you get hit with a couple
drops of rain oh my God who gives a
[__] but in the way it gets you going
it's a different way of getting going
outside coffee and all these things you
let nature get you going if you were
around 8,000 [__] years ago you'd
wake up outside
and youd breathe that air and guess what
people didn't sit around and talk and
read the [__] paper they got up and
killed [__] I know you said
you've done this like this was you
before you went to prison but did prison
have anything to do with it not being
able to go outside no not at all I
remember being a kid and living in in U
Manhattan on 89th Street mhm that's my
first memory of a real home and we had
in those days it was an apartment but
you walked into the apartment it was a
living room then there was a kitchen and
in the kitchen you open the sliding gate
okay and it was like 12 x 12 whatever
the [__] those things are you know and I
remember I just sit out there and look
at the sun I could have been four I
don't know what the [__] I was waiting
for I didn't have I was waiting for
[__] uh rainbow or nothing I was just
a [__] little four-year-old kid and
I would just sit there and look at the
Sun and go to myself how [__]
beautiful is this did you ever have
dinner outside that was the I had a deck
too I would I would watch TV and when I
would get bored yeah I'd go on that
balcony and I'd sit in the corner and my
mom would say why do you sit out here
it's better than sitting there I'm
breathing there I look if if you look
down in those days you saw
garbage if I don't like eating outside
really no I don't like eating outside
especially when become in this country
people eat outside to show you they're
outside look at us with an umbrella put
me in the back looking forward to
somebody comes in I slip out the
bathroom door well I don't understand it
at restaurants especially when
no that's a jerk off thing that's since
I I I used to date a girl that that was
a thing let's sit outside what do they
call it sus fresa I go Fresco go [__]
yourself Fresco put me in the back and
I'll look forward I don't want no
outside germs and no [__] people
breathing it's a dog you ever see people
handle your food oh they grab the food
and the [__] that stop to
answer a question I'll break the dish
over a [__] head you know what I'm
talking about like they have your food
and they'll stop talk talk
they'll talk and your food will be just
sitting there out cuz you're you're
looking at them from the kitchen I look
at everybody I don't no no no no no no
no Uncle Joey keeps that eye on that
waiter I got one eye on the waiter and
the other eye on the [__] door the
part that gets me cuz I used to be a
waiter is like the thumb at in in the
drinking glass or the thumb touching
like your food as as they're bringing it
to you or like if you're at like a the
thumb is the was least of my prom just a
little tip of a thumb was the last time
you put your thumb up your ass you don't
you put it in your mouth the thing that
bothers me the most is when they stop
with your food to talk and cools down
that no it doesn't cool down the breath
you're talking and my food your [__]
germs are sticking to my [__] food
and his germs are sticking to your food
how do you know which way it is to the
bathroom I have no [__] idea I'm
carrying food that way but you don't
stop with my three [__] dishes to
talk to somebody that's my point and
getting their breath on your food yeah
that's what I don't like that's what I'm
talking about I don't give a [__] about
a thumb okay yeah I don't like this
country is worried about thumbs and he
had hair who gives a [__] if you're any
type of Civilian you've been sucking
dick for 30 years how many hairs have
you had in your mouth you got more hairs
than on the [__] OJ crime [__]
scene you what I'm saying and right away
you don't want to [__] but it's
different I don't know what it it
doesn't bug because listen let me
explain something to you that you need
to understand before you get into
anything okay when you walk into a
restroom you have to assume in the back
of your mind that this guy scratched his
balls and picked up your meat you have
to assume that the letuce guy because if
you don't you're a [__]
idiot I try to put it out of my head I
guess yeah we all do as Americans you
try to put it out of your head when you
eat but what do you think happens in a
[__] kitchen what do you think really
happens you know that food that you like
all those let me ask you something all
these restaurants that [__] that dude
Bar Rescue go to right they're the
restaurants you go to the same type of
food you like
you know that dude that you were raving
about oh yeah had carnas on the sandwich
listen that guy will be out of business
in a year and he's a filthy [__] back
there because those carnas who's eating
a [__] carnita sandwich the only one
that's doing that is you carnas is
nobody has come up to me in the last
four weeks and said I found this place
and they had carnita sandwich with Swiss
cheese or cheddar that's even [__]
worse we discussed cheddar today you
hate cheddar I don't know what it is
delicious it's not it's not delicious
it's not a good cheese at all doesn't do
anything to a sandwich but makes you
[__] white as [__] that's all chedda
does chedda is not Swiss chedd is not
monster so what cheeses are passible
American sliced
thin sliced thin on on Turkey taste it
sometimes thin with mayonnaise taste
that [__] it conglomerates better
than that hard cancer that chedd is a
hard [__] cancer don't you look at
that [__] cheddar I don't think it's
a cancer but maybe who knows I like
Swiss
Swiss is a call for ham Swiss is a call
for [__] turkey with change little
Swiss little Swiss on roast beef with
change on R bread you have no idea what
you're getting yourself
into you have no idea with the little
seeds in it a little rye bread with some
roast beef sliced thin a little pink
throw some salt and pepper on that
[__] throw a slice of Swiss
cheese or two a little shaved lettuce
very important shaved lettuce is that
little little strips little strips and
the slices of tomato on rye with
mayonnaise and then come back and you
see your uncle [__] Joey if that's
not your
sandwich I used to get pissed at my mom
cuz I loved something when you there's
something about shaved lettuce that
tastes different opposed to like one
leaf of lettuce complet that leaf I take
that thing and I go yeah I don't want
this when they just put the leaf of
lettuce in I don't want that I like when
they put the spinach in and all that
type of stuff like the spinach leaves I
don't mind that okay but shredded
lettuce is the call when you go down to
Jersey Shore it's shredded [__]
lettuce when you go to hashway Deli it's
shredded [__] delas when you go to
dama in Fair View it's shredded [__]
lettuce what part of that doesn't
anybody [__] understand it's I think
it's laziness I guess yeah it's laziness
it's [__] complete laziness that's
why I can't you know you can't go to
those places cuz if you go you just fall
into that [__] trap you just have to
boycott those places in your mind
everyone makes fun of you for like have
like your stances and stuff
but it gets you out a lot of bad like
you never have like a really like a bad
meal no just like I stick to my guns
right yeah I stick to my guns I love to
try new things but I look at the person
who suggested it and I look at the other
Foods he's told me about in his [__]
stupid [__] life do you still take
advice from me or no no not even close
you you're disgusting you like carne s
on French fries that's doesn't like it's
delicious car s fries that's just
garbage Lee that's just garbage a nice
[__] steak fry nice with an open
steak sandwich that's the way America a
[__] carned you don't know what the
[__] a carned is it could be a pork
knuckle I saw that meat they served at
that thing the other day where at that
[__] benefit I went to it was
disgusting yeah bad me it's really when
they listen when they ex when people
created all these meals they have to
evolve but nobody in their right mind
had the [__] they going to put on French
fries now I mean how many things can you
put on French fries I until you're
[__] ridiculous there's nothing I
like on a french fry except ketchup a
nice cut
potato from the house and you and you uh
cut steak fries doesn't need anything if
you want to dope it up with some garlic
slices thin and some onion
slices that's it that's all that needs
it doesn't need you know nothing else
when I grew up in Jersey I used to go to
those places that had the gravy with the
mozzarella cheese that's [__]
delicious but you don't see me eating it
every week you can't you can't
you know you you throw those weights
around three times a week you want me to
tell you what I ate today what do you
tell you what I ate today I woke up this
morning I had an alond smoothie I need
dick you know what I had for lunch I had
a steak in eggs with fruit and a piece
of wheat toast that's good I eat nothing
else and then tonight my wife made some
[__] fukasha hamburger help right two
[__] spoons of it t now I have a
protein shake I'm not better than you
and I'm trying to to to eat better but I
never like if I knew now when I knew at
your age I wouldn't eat half the [__] I
was eating I would just refuse to eat it
and I did I when I tell you I'm not
going to do listen I hate my one friend
but one thing he always told me is when
you I was telling Larry this last night
on the phone he's like when when I put
something in my head it's over I'll
never look at that food again I'll never
eat there again I'll never go back there
again I don't care what they tell you
and I grew up at a time when there was
no yel when you made a personal [__]
choice you made a personal thing I don't
check yel because look at the the people
who are going on y they don't know about
food what do they know about
food they've been growing up out here
eating this [__] the [__] do they know
about food nothing a carnita fry who's
ever heard of
that I guess with cheese on it it's so
good you know how hard you work yeah I
can't eat them and I don't I don't I
never have it's like it's over like like
at one point you look at that food and
go like it's never happening ever again
like that's it never again it can't
happen like that's the discipline that
America has never really understood with
anything whether it's drugs or food or a
pill or anything and and everything that
goes with that has to be shut down I.E
somebody calls you and says hey I'm
having a party at that place I going
there why cuz they have carnito fries I
won't even step in the building no no no
no it's just little things that people
and then we go back on and then we get
angry with ourselves I should have never
came here you knew it you [__] knew
it
2,000 million people are not wrong Jared
tricked the whole [__] nation into
eating that horse meat it's terrible
it's [__] terrible and if you say to
me well Joey it's a sandwich for $5 do
you know the sandwich I can make you for
five [__] dollars you have any
[__] idea the sandwich I can make you
for five [__] dollars yeah the
sandwich you can make yourself for five
[__] dollars but you have to go to
the store who gives a [__] a lot of
people wouldn't you rather go to the
store than have [__] that tattoo guy
with greasy fingers he's been smoking
cigarettes I don't give a [__] how many
gloves at Subway one of those [__]
foreigners put on their hands and that
white dude with the tattoo of an
alligator on his neck he could put on
three [__] gloves and the stench of
his life is still going to touch that
[__] disgusting turkey pastrami they
get that you're going to eat $5 you're
selling your [__]
soul you're selling your soul and then
it's just [__] it's not good at all
even for even for to save
no nutritional value at all that's what
I'm [__] saying with half of these
half of these places you go eat at now
dog are Alla Fusion everybody wants to
be Johnny [__] fusion and they all
when did that start do you remember yeah
D I'm sitting on my balcony last Friday
it's me and my wife we're talking it's
[__] 2: in the afternoon I went to
who the [__] knows what happened I know
I'm
starving I look on the table there's a
[__] menu all right it's for I look
at the
thing it says spicy garlic shrimp that
sounds good said godamn where is this I
told my wife we went down there first as
I'm walking in I kick myself in the ass
it was one of those mixed places it was
half Japanese and half Chinese right
already the hairs on my neck stuck out
already but I go you know what I got to
be fair I got to talk myself through
this why be negative I could be positive
well let me tell you something the
[__] fried wons tasted like terrible
even my wife were like what are these
things the [__] Philly Philly roll
roll the cream cheese with was 2 years
old okay the shrimp and garlic was okay
but they gave me those [__] metam M
shrimp once I see those shrimp I got to
go the rice was the best thing on the
menu the white rice will I go there
again never in my [__] whole life was
it my fault absolutely cuz I don't go in
my world you got to pick a country
either Chinese or Japanese you can't
sell Sushi and pork fried [__] rice
and every time you go to those places
you're going to end up going wow this
ain't that good no because they can't
even make good Japanese food now they
want to try to cross [__] over then
want to cross over and then the problem
I have with going out to eat I can't I
have a terrible time making choices like
I'll spend two hours and it's because I
don't I I'll go to these places that oh
I had a bad meal there but I'll try them
again like it seems like you just if you
if you make a decision and just stick to
it it makes your life a lot simpler
which I have day you said to me I went
to this place got a burger why don't you
go to St well because I don't give a
[__] what Paula thinks I don't give a
[__] what anybody thinks my wife Paula
your wife if somebody comes out here to
visit me and says Hi I was in a bar in
in in Jersey and I heard about this
place called five fingers Burgers five
brothers whatever the [__] it is can we
go there and get a hamburger yeah on
your own you want a burger yeah we're
going to stop why are we going to stop
you don't get bored of any of these
places no but I don't go every [__]
week okay but it's the best burger why
[__] around I'm not going to go anywhere
else there's no reason to go anywhere
else the fries suck dick there but the
burger is the best burger in town the
thing to do is to go to Jerry get steak
fries go to Stout get a burger and bring
it home that's your best bet but I'm not
that much of a [__] animal that is
the best bet I love doing that okay
that's what I'm saying to you I wouldn't
go anywhere else for a burger right now
nowhere else the next 10 years will I
live here there's no reason to that
[__] Burger is the best burger the
flavor in that burger I've been all over
the country that's the best burger I've
had in 10 [__] years inside that
burger how they cook it the pink it's
real meat you never get sick there the
onion rings are [__] tremend
tremendous in the iced tea I'm not going
to recommend anything else to you there
I don't know I never had it but when I
want a hamburger one of my friend I want
a hamburger and my friend Julius says
this's a place in Sherman I was listen
then go with Julius right yeah go with
Julius but today we're going to Stout
and I guarantee you'll love it and
that's it it always works it's not that
I'm being a prick or it's not that I'm
being a bad person I go for what's the
best bang for my [__]
D how did you get so confident cuz I
don't have it at all man you just grow
and you go this is what I'm going to do
and this is what I'm not going to
do that's it this is what I'm going to
do and this is where I'm not going to
go you know yesterday was the first time
that we got uh it was too hot to cook
yesterday right so yesterday I was going
to Jiu-Jitsu on the way back I'm
starving Jerry roacher calls me we're
talking and he goes I'm going I'm at the
Golden
Chopsticks I said you know what a
Chinese lunch wouldn't [__] kill you
so I got the chicken pepper you know
just nice chicken with brown rice you
know wasn't bad but that's not Chinese
food any idiot can make a piece of
chicken with brown rice do you know what
I'm saying right like I had a settle for
[__] chicken with red peppers you
know those little red spicy peppers
that's not what I would have got there
no but they don't have sesan beef the
way I like it they don't have anything
and you know they can't mess it up right
so I know they can't [__] it up so I
take the easy Rod out so nobody gets
their feelings so but like that that
there's that Chinese place on ment I
went there with my wife and my wife was
pregnant they got me one time for 60
don't ever get me again it was
disgusting until one day I said I'm not
eating Chinese food no more what does
that mean I'm just not doing it no more
when I go home to chance I'll stack up
there's no reason to eat that [__]
otherwise it's just bad the only thing I
like around here is that [__] uh
seshan oh the green apple the green
apple but who's going to I got to go
park and go on the tunnel moves and no
forget it and that's why I don't going
back to why I don't leave the house I
think about all that and then I'm like
why even leave the house why you even go
outside you think about all that but
you'll settle for a shitty restaurant
instead of just going to because I get
overwhelmed I'm like oh [__] it I'll
just go there why would you get
overwhelmed it's like America with TV
today nobody could have a decent TV show
today it's not even worth trying to put
a decent TV show on today because there
is so overwhelming of television there
was so much entertainment if I want to
stay home if I wanted to be a 500 lb fat
[__] I could do it in today's world just
staying home easily it wouldn't even be
hard easily they've programmed this to
to for you to stay home and watch that
[__] all [__] day there's a new show
on Netflix there a new show on this
there's a new show on that so no show
could really grab you I hear the hottest
show is that family [__] show on
ABC uh Modern Family there is not one
person I talk to that watches that
number two every every show I've seen on
ABC the last two years is so God awful
it's so God
awful I told my wife this last week
we're watching something I I I can't
even watch Shark Tank no more really
it's getting a little weird yeah it's
getting too cocky now and Shark Tank
plus who gives a [__] give me the money
and not you're going to rob me anyway
what's the big [__] deal I'm getting
robbed here no matter what something you
see the fine print at the end with the
yeah yeah it's fine print like a
[__] at the end so it is kind of
crazy with especially with that show
that we've been convinced into watching
an hourong of commercials we they that's
what that's a a commercial for their
companies and their products and it's
amazing that that's well you're really
buying them out of all the shows I'll
watch shark that's I watch it every week
I'll watch it but it's so weird how
people glorify these other [__] shows
and I try to watch them and I'm like I
don't know what these people but this
for me it's been like that all my life I
could look through something I could see
two or three little things and go the
same for me you know I was talking to
Larry yesterday I love Las Vegas I love
the idea of moving to Las Vegas but what
was he yesterday like 110 that's the way
it is for three [__] months no thank
you you know what man you don't have
enough air conditions for me at this age
I know exactly what I'm going to do and
I know exactly what I'm not going to
[__] do I know I'm not going to ever
eat broccoli I know I'm never going to
eat [__]
asparagus I I already know cuz I haven't
done it already and I won't [__]
break for it at all I don't give a [__]
what's wrong with broccoli I just don't
like none of that [__] I don't I like
lettuce tomato and onions that's it but
only shredded lettuce shredded lettuce
for different
things you can't give me a salad at home
with shredded lettuce you look like a
[__] [__] you have to cut the
lettuce do you understand me and that's
what all these people have messed up out
here that's what they you know it only
takes a little bit more to be that much
better I open up a sandwich shop guess
what I'm going to do before I open up a
sandwich shop what I'm taking my fat
[__] friend leeam me and we're going
to get a big bag of reefer and we're
going to go to the 10 top sandwich shops
in the country that's how you open up a
[__] business that's the investment
you go to Jersey and you go guys give me
the best [__] sandwich pie you hear
10 guys vetos [__] mookies you do a
thing and whoever has 11 out of 12 you
[__] go to them then you go to New
York City who's got the best sandwich
this place you go and you eat the
sandwiches and you learn then you go to
Oklahoma you eat a sandwich in Oklahoma
you you almost puke I tell I had
sandwich in Omaha I almost [__] puked
what happened oh my God it was just
something that they couldn't even make a
sandwich but I knew this going in and
this is what you get when you go to
those small little [__]
airports you're so hard on yourself this
is what you get that is it's true you
you reach a certain age that you already
know what you're getting yourself
[__] involved in that's about 34 35
you know you're going to get sucked into
this stupid [__] that's why like I had a
friend who got hooked on coke at 50 and
crack at 50 I never saw that oh God
after all of life that's been happening
at 45 you want to get hooked on crack
and smoke crack and all this [__] now
that's crazy yeah were they sober up
until that point or well not really you
know they were still [__] uh doing
[__] but now they smoke crack out of
everything at that age yeah that's
intense
crack it's weird especially cuz when I
used to look at people my age now and
think I was old but now when you when
you when I'm growing up and seeing like
I I live next to this woman who is very
nice but I I'm pretty sure she's a
hoarder she doesn't leave the house it's
really it's it gets kind of creepy after
a certain age for a lot of people like
it's it's it's sad it's it's weird how
people just deteriorate well not
deteriorate but no but listen that
deterioration process you have two
choices you can let yourself deteriorate
it you can do something about it
m you're following me man I mean I've
never had it like can't imagine what
it's like to lose the will to
live I want to live every day as bad as
my life was there was something I knew
that there was something over the
[__] Hill that's the only way I could
describe it when you get up in the
morning and you realize where you're at
and then you start thinking about your
life and right before you [__] go
into a [__] coma of
depression you [__] look up and it's
like there's something over the hill and
you run in the shower and while you're
in the shower you give yourself that
confidence but I can't imagine what it's
like not to have the will to live not to
have the will and it's not about money I
know people who had millions of dollars
that they lose the will to live and I
just always thought life was [__]
great like I no matter how bad it was I
never saw it and I got to tell you I
felt bad in a lot of times in my life
I'm not going to [__] sit here and
tell you that there was years I didn't
know
what the next level was or so when you
were homeless you didn't feel that
way when I was homeless doing all that
[__] I got to tell you I knew that I was
putting myself in this position but part
of it wasn't that I wanted to do it
Lee it was that this is where I wanted
to
be I didn't think I was good enough
to do that other
stuff so is that complicated for you
like when you say listen half the coke I
did I didn't want to
do half the [__] I did do you think I
really wanted to [__] break into
somebody's house I didn't want to
[__] do that at all it was there was
19 or 20
factors I could have got a job League
I'm capable man don't let me [__]
[__] you yeah I don't have a I'm not
a college educated and I don't use B big
words but you take me into your office
and you give me a week or two and I'll
figure out what the [__] you're doing
and all that four years of college you
went to school for you're going to go
boy was I stupid you following me I mean
you really have to think of all the
things you could do and learn on your
own if you really have the desire to do
it if you really want to be a [__]
camera guy you know and okay Joey but I
only make $200 a week at my sandwich
place then you put away $25
and you get yourself a $150 camera and
you just start shoot you know what I'm
saying when you really think about it
there's so many things that you really
could be doing if you really wanted to
do
them that's I think that's the hardest
part though and that when I say I have
anxiety a lot of it comes from starting
[__] once I start something I'm good but
I'll go back and forth it it started
when I was a kid with homework it it it
continues now with with my professional
a lot of professional stuff I'll I'll
well I'm going to tell you something
that's really really funny you mention
homework when I got out of Catholic
School you had a certain time period to
do homework so I was pretty much trained
okay you had uh I think you had like a
5: to 6:30 was homework and then you ate
dinner or you ate dinner and did
homework don't quote me on this I don't
know exactly what the thing
was so I went to sixth grade in North
Bergan and in those days I used since I
had been brutalized to do homework
between a certain hour I would do
homework at night before I went to bed
just because [__] them [__] the nuns
[__] the nuns yeah but then when I got
left
back I always did my homework first and
got it
over
even those years I was at North Bergen
and my mom had died and I would do acid
with those guys after school if I had a
project I would go to school early and
do homework at school just go to the
cafeteria sit there by by myself I
wouldn't even go to study cuz then
people would see me you know if if if
Lee got out of school I think uh it was
238 and the last class went till 2:34 I
used to go to school at 7:00 but I get
out at 12:15 every day because I was
part of the cie work study program so
you got 15 credits to work oh nice yeah
getting out at noon every day
yeah so sometimes I would just call the
lumber yard and go I'm not going to be
that till 3: I knew I was going to do
acid that night so right at 12:15 I'd
get my books and I'd run to the
cafeteria or somewhere that nobody could
see me and I'd do my [__] homework
and I just leave it in the locker that's
how organized I got even just getting
the fact of getting left back I never
procrastinated with school workk again
even when I enrolled later on at
Colorado Mountain College and I started
going to see you at night and all that
[__] I never procrastinate ated homework
and it still sticks with me today like
this podcast sheet gets prepped Sunday
for the whole week yeah except for the
names for the shout outs wow okay
everything gets programmed because I
like my homework you got to have
homework and just get it done and listen
you have a CH when you got to do
something do it and get it over with
yeah and I didn't learn that from
[__] nobody you know what I what I
learned on sford and Son Fred sford told
the m one time when you got to do
something do it and get it over with
that's why I call it work it's not easy
they call it
work they call all this [__] work for a
reason do you ever it's been going crazy
in my mind it's
work I was pretty lucky in school I I
would do the homework but for tests and
for all that stuff really I would study
a little bit maybe but I could pretty
much do nothing and get a
b and I really think it [__] with me I
think
I think it hurt me in life because and
it's not like it's not like my parents
were sitting like oh you're the best I'm
sure they did that a little bit but it I
honestly think me not having to put the
work in back
then has really helped me back in work
cuz it's still I still sometimes take a
to a long time to get started or I'll
put something off if I know I have until
3:00 on Thursday I'll wait until 1:30 on
Thursday rather than finishing it on
Monday for no reason
I'll it'll take me a few days to get
started and stuff but in the meantime
I'll make notes and that's the excuse
I'll give myself so I'll make notes at
least so when I sit down I could start
doing whatever the [__] I got to
do uh taking care of the [__] in front
of you is so important being on top of
your schedule is so important and I can
tell you this from not having a schedule
to being on top of it it's two different
[__] worlds sometimes it's too creepy
like it's too creepy because you held
too much to your schedule but it's not
bad no way because it makes you be more
productive with your day well I would
imagine if you're going from no schedule
to schedule you might overshoot a little
bit and then just have to dial it back
to we like a happy medium between being
scheduled and then having some free I
try to break everything into twoh hour
chunks okay I'll write for two hours
I'll do business for 2 hours I'll go to
Jiu-Jitsu for 2 hours I'll come back and
write for 2 hours
then I'll talk to my wife for an hour
see what's going on with the house look
at the mail with her talk to her about
this or that you know you have to keep
evolving I can't sit at one place for
that long I know when I sit down in the
morning what I got to do on the computer
and there's times I'm doing four [__]
things at once that's the beauty of the
computer I could be answering emails on
Facebook sending emails on
Hotmail twitting a [__] and [__]
[__] answering
Gmail yeah absolutely you know it's so
weird that's how and a notebook in front
of me with the earphones on listen to
music and the notebook has jokes but the
other notebook is the people I got to
contact them why and then on the back of
that page I write that I contacted them
with a result and what happened this is
all at once so I'm juggling six [__]
things I'm on Facebook wri and suck my
dick it's Wednesday
then I'm on YouTube blasting the song
then I go over the [__] hot mail I
answer this [__] Momo then I go over
to Twitter and write that out and answer
three people there and then from there I
take that to the notebook and I go that
dude just gave me a [__] joke by
mistake and I write it down the notes
and I try to make it funny and then on
top of all that I look at the other
notebook and I go holy [__] I gotta call
Andrea I think that's brilliant because
here's here's an issue I
have you you've been you were big on me
for a while to make make sure you tweet
and Facebook at least once a day like
I'm I've been trying to get better at it
so in the mornings I sit down and I try
to think about what I want to say but a
lot of times if I'm stuck on what I want
to say I'll just sit there and do
nothing and you said it forever to have
two notebooks have a couple things open
get up take a shower once you're dead
you're dead you have you're in no
position to sit anywhere for a [__]
hour you're 26 years old you can't sit
there staring out into the world looking
like a [__] Momo you got to get up
and right there when you start going in
the shower right there when you start
you should be hitting the balcony
hitting that pipe okay and shooting into
the shower and by the time you get out
of the shower you'll have something to
say and you just did three birds at one
stone that's how productive you were all
in one [__] Loop so you get up from
the computer go in the bathroom put the
hot water on only that's it hot water on
only close that [__] door go out to
that backyard and hit that [__]
toots put that down and go in there now
put the cold water on so the [__]
floor gets nice and hot for your feet
and now you get in there and you you got
steam to open up your pores and then you
put the cold water on [__] you and your
drought if it takes 8 minutes to smoke
the bowl it takes 8 minutes if it takes
10 seconds what whatever it looks like
[__] some hippie don't take a shower
today big deal he ain't missing
water you so by the time you go back in
there in 8 minutes it's steamed right
you go in there you get your [__]
loofer you could shave
do everything in one [__]
shot and usually if you have the
Smoothie early by the time you doing the
Twitter you got a [__] so now you smoke
dope you sit on the throne it's steamy
in there the problem with hot air and
[__] is it thickens in there it's not
good it lurks in there like a [__]
herpes it lurks it smells for a little
while but you flush it you give that
[__] [__] water you let the hot water
turn cold for a minute and now you
killed they birds are once St you
[__] smoked took a [__] made a
smoothie showered shaved shampoo you put
cream on your legs you clean out your
ears with the Q-tips you put Visine in
your ey ball so nobody knows you're
[__] stoned you know your Listerine
you know this is all right there by the
time I get out of the shower my clothes
are on the [__]
bedly I already got the clothes on the
way in to smoke that's what I did I took
a pair of shorts out socks and I throw
them across to the [__] bed that
that's productivity in your [__] day
I think multitasking has got a bad rap
recently I'm not who gives a [__] got a
bad rap who by [__] people are lazy
that's not multitasking that's being
productive that's not going any
direction without an empty hand that's
what that's call not making a move
without an empty hand why am I making
this move all the way over there without
an empty hand for what can I take to the
[__] kitchen this glass that's been
sitting here for three [__] weeks
right yeah so now I got a plan as soon
as I got up I got a [__] plan I'm
going to go into that kitchen eat
whatever boom back to the bathroom put
the hot water on out smoke go back [__]
Boom by the time I get out clothes
everything's ready to go that's called
productivity and if you can't do that in
your house how the [__] are you going to
do it at
work right how are you going to do it at
work who the [__] says multitasking is
multitasking because I tell you what
happens to people a they multitask
without a
list like my wife they multitask without
a LIF a list or being prepared to that
multitask why is the list so important
because it follows you you follow to the
blueprint so it makes the multitask a
lot [__] easier what do you think I
could just juggle three [__] balls no
but if I write every
move if I know every move when I get up
that multitask I just saved [__] two
hours of Labor
and it is it because people get like
like oh I I I'm I'm so busy I can't I
can't spend 10 minutes and write a list
but that list would save him three hours
that list is what you do at night before
you go to bed or that morning while
you're drinking your
coffee again you're multitasking you're
not just sitting there you ever see
people drink coffee and smoke a
cigarette and look out into the Horizon
you know sit on your balcony no I always
wanted to see somebody just a bullet go
into their head and they fall backwards
if you're sitting there even the [__]
like I didn't listen I don't know
nothing about nothing dog I don't know
nothing about nothing but but I didn't
do it one
thing when I started doing comedy I
would wake up in the morning I'd be
angry okay and sometimes I'd be sad and
sometimes I'd be I'd be anxious I don't
know this happened like in
1994 and one day I Sho with through a
notebook I don't [__] know and I woke
up every morning morning and I
wrote Tuesday June 21st by this time I
wasn't even sharp enough to write it's a
beautiful day to be
alive I would say it to myself from time
to time but I didn't believe it you know
and I would just write what I woke up
with oh my God Lee when you read that
notebook a week later you're just
draining what's in there cut two two
years later I'm dating this check and
she's telling me about the writer's way
or whatever and that's what they're
supposed to do in the morning
I didn't cheat I didn't copy from them I
was doing this two years before I met
this [__] bro so you you just write
all the thoughts that were in your head
from the night before okay and those
thoughts turn into your schedule so how
many thoughts you got I want to [__]
Paula I got to take finny to the cat I
got to do something about my mom and I
got to do something about my dad you
know I got to do this I got to do that
and then all a sudden you write another
line and go okay what time is it and
you're still drinking your coffee
you're still drinking your coffee now
you already should have the anchors for
your your day you should have had an
anchor in there written on Sunday
there's got to be something in there for
Thursday when you open up that notebook
that you wrote in there on Sunday it's
got to be an anchor what if you have
nothing what do you put down you better
put down [__] you're going to do
something what the [__] are you going to
do you better put something down there's
got to be something you can [__]
do so even if it's an appointment just I
put 12:00 BJJ okay got it if there's
nothing on that [__] list I put 12:00
BJJ and you put right one hour you could
do that and look around your room
there's got to be something you can
[__] do to fix your desk or to make
yourself more efficient so if you don't
have something you give yourself
something from 9 to 5 you never have the
power to watch TV or that's for
amateures 8 to 6 that's for [__] news
that's it from 8 to five you better find
something to [__] do that's something
everybody could do how does this change
when you're looking for a job in which
way cuz you don't necessarily have a
full 9 to5 schedule but I know there's a
lot of people out there who are looking
for jobs and are are are frustrated
there's a lot of people who whenever you
hear like the uh how does this find how
does this look when you find the job
yeah if I was 26 uh-huh I'd be up at
6:00 in the [__] morning every
morning
okay I'd be up at 600 in the morning
morning those websites they work but you
got to take it a little deeper those
guys get 2 million, reses in morning M
they don't really have time to look at
everybody this is where people say well
you need to have connections no you need
to make connections and how you make
connections is by stop being [__]
lazy see where the office is see where
the HR office is everybody has an HR
office every [__] big corporation
that you want to work today has to have
a what do they call that human resources
Human Resources office I want I want to
get down there I want to know who makes
the decisions and I ain't got time to
email something but they said don't come
they said I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] what they tell you want a
[__] job right right you got to show
down there did you not read the mem
you're not supposed to come down here no
my brother Joey Diaz told me that that
they were looking and to just come down
and see some lady named Samantha who's
Samantha right away you got conversation
right away you got conversation you just
make up a name oh yeah my friend Peter
Patell told me to come down here and see
Sam Mana but wait a second how did you
find out I'm a college graduate I've
been looking for a job you just selling
yourself you you got one minute to talk
talk talk you're a dummy you're not
really a dummy I don't care I don't care
if you're a [__] a chemist from
Harvard right there you're playing a
dummy my friend Mike Mike Mike Jesus
told me he's a [__] up Jew just start
talking start talking I name is Samantha
I just want to drop this off you mean
Rebecca boom oh I'm sorry yeah and oh
let me put Rebecca on there guess who's
getting a call tomorrow at 10:00 in the
morning
Rebecca and [__] there you go that's
brilliant there you go what's the
[__] big I Lally and then you're
there you go the job cuz you're there I
swear to my mother's grave and to all
the viewers that are watching I'm was a
worthless piece of [__] at the age of 25
what I'm about to tell you people might
even make me cry I was a worthless piece
of [__] at the the age of 25 I couldn't
be trusted I couldn't do nothing but
there was one thing I could do was get a
job fake
references names guys I can't do much
I'm telling you right now if you listen
to these if you listen to this podcast
from the beginning I was a plumber eight
times I was an electrician I was a hard
carrier I was a Carpenters helper I was
a car salesman I worked at a body shop I
worked at a shoe store I worked at benan
as a [__] cook for two hours you know
I worked at gas stations I worked at a
[__] meat place guys do you
understand me I'm a [__] stiff but
what kept me alive was the ability to
walk into these [__] office and
you got one minute to sell yourself did
you just see what I just did looking for
Samantha who's Samantha the lady who
hires here you mean Rebecca oh there you
go I didn't even do nothing and do you
do like the thing where you don't answer
their questions you just keep talking
cuz like I would get ner like you're
going to get in trouble like oh oh so
sorry you're not going to keep talking I
mean like a [__]
[__] sorry about that people you're not
going to keep talking like a [__]
[__] but you're going to keep talking
that you're panicking a little Panic
you're embarrassed this is really
embarrassing you you were told something
and that's not the case oh my God oh my
God I am
flabbergasted Nikki dudo told me to come
here here and give Samantha who's
Samantha this is after you know it's
Rebecca okay this is even after you know
it's Rebecca you drop another Samantha
Anna and now she tells you the last name
you mean Samantha Cochran yeah okay huh
there you
go oh my God you got a website info you
got an email on the
website here you go but if you don't do
that see and now you're going you're
listening going Joey that's not going to
get you the job it's not but if you do
10 of those you got a better chance of
just clicking that thing on the interet
I I worked for a pretty big production
company this guy just walked in around
the office Park one day with resumes and
he got hired it turned out he was an
idiot because we've forgotten well that
idiot knows how to get a job I just told
you the job Yeah by while you're at home
fascinating over your degree and what
your parents paid and the loans you took
and you're Feathering your [__] you
got to really think about what you're
qualified for and especially today's
economy so you got to lower your
standards a little bit and you got to do
[__] that they might not be able to do
Lee I listen I just told you this story
about human resources from what I've
heard yeah you know when I was going to
places you thought you dealt with a
manager okay so lisak calls me up and he
says listen
uh Joey they're looking for my sister
works at the Sheridan Center they're
looking for bartenders for the front no
[__]
okay what do you do
Lee what do I do I go and I try to find
a manager who's
working probably during off
hours so I can introduce myself and and
try to get a
job the manager you going to go to
aart for bartender I would probably go
to I would think manager but go to the
manager first okay but eight maybe
become friends at the bartender maybe go
work to bartender first go go and get a
soda because he could be the manager
give it a nice tip no just talk to him
how you doing listen can I ask you a
question
again I just worked at
[__] this place for eight years I'm
looking for a job my friend Nicki dudo
who's Nicki the I have no idea doesn't
really matter who he is nine out of 10
times people look at you and go oh yeah
I know Nick and you're sitting there
going cuz I don't want to be embarrassed
and yeah forget somebody so you you
don't have an idea just make up a name
Pete Rose really oh my God I love Pete
listen you guys looking for parttime I
love to work here I'm really good with
crowd whatever nah listen come back at
3:30 the boom there you go there you go
you give the guy the fin now when you
walk in he's going to go over and said
this guy worked at the Regency hotel for
six years he knows backwards how do you
know because he came in here earlier
looking for any tip look at look how
nice his shoes are
shined you're looking for a job job if
you're looking for a job making $8 an
hour you don't have to shine your shoes
but if you're looking for a job making
over $60,000 or
$250,000 your shoes better get shined
every time you leave the house because
I'm a bum from the street and that's the
first thing I look at really you look at
your shoes first thing I look at if you
don't have time to shine two pieces of
[__] thing why would I want you
working for me and we've spoken about it
before but that's weird in this town
LA's like you know you never dress up
for job interviews here that's why you
don't get theob
right well you know I would agree with
you mostly but in La I've been to places
where people like laugh at people who
dress up here you have to half
dress you have to half ass
dress okay you're not going to wear a
suit with a [__] tie you know but a
light jacket with a shirt that's
open and shiny shoes with a belt that
matches the shoes just something to let
them know you know you
can't get a $10,000 check with a $10
presentation did you see that special we
mhm first of all the special my material
sucked my my my timing sucked but the
first thing that sucked was what our man
Larry said the
Wardrobe I look like a bump from the
street now in my personal life I like to
look like a bum from the street I don't
want people get confused I'm not that
guy I'm not going to put on a Versace
suit and walk around to make you feel
bad okay okay I am who the [__] I am I
got you know how many pairs of new
Adidas I got in my [__] closet up in
the top shelf how many four brand new in
the box I get from Amazon look at the
ones I got on Old yeah okay my socks are
clean my shorts are brand new the
t-shirts I just bought at the Fatman
store but do you understand I don't ever
want to give people an illusion that I'm
I don't need to dress in a [__]
polyester suit or whatever I got suits I
got shirts but when you go for a job
okay last [__]
Monday I went to meet with these
guys I know these guys I went to meet
them at Arts okay you know what I had on
what do you have on a pair of jeans with
a little hole in the back pocket a
t-shirt with these dirty sneakers do you
know what I was supposed to leave the
house at [__] 9:10 at 9:15 I was
putting on iron jeans with a nice shirt
I just got and brand new Adidas I put my
rings on I put my chain on I put my hair
do down there and you know what I'm
doing that show tomorrow night and I got
a meeting with them next Tuesday because
if you don't feel good and and guys I
didn't know this till later on either
but if you don't feel good you're not
going to
[__] how yeah how different did you
feel from the tremendous I had the
confidence of a thousand you know I went
there looking like Charles Bronson I'm
going to go go that dress like Charles
Bronson why oh my Charles Bronson no you
got to dress nice and even if they dress
like [__] bums you dress a little
better than them and you out dress them
if your sneakers are white and clean you
know if your pants are ironed if you
don't have a stain I had a stain on my
shirt t i at a special right yeah a
stain on my shirt do you know what
that's
like just take that film and burn it I
mean filing those guys ain't never going
to send it back that's been eight months
right yeah we'll clean it up and send it
back to you in a month that's never
going to
[__] I knew how to get a job even
today when I go to audition for a movie
I'm not better than half of these guys
look at my face look like a [__] bus
hit it but when I walk in there Jack I
don't give a Frenchman's [__] I know my
lines I've done it 18 times where I walk
around I know exactly how I would answer
the door how I would turn the light bulb
off what hand I would do it with that
shows them you're prepared man did I
[__] know this at 22 I knew half of
it I knew half of
it how long did it take for the rest of
the half to come in 20
years I have to give you credit man I
brought Donuts to an appointment I had
yesterday and it [__] okay so it
[__] blew the room up okay see you
could have been a real douche bag I mean
listen
the I I think I mentioned it last week
the guy around here with the convertible
I see a convertible BMW I see a [__]
douchebag yeah all right but I see
a I see a nice guy okay now I'm against
this too guys in fact next week when I
come back I got to really take care of
it living in that [__] thing over
there with those trees destroys my car I
can't wash my car enough then I get in
there with the karate [__] listen at
Jiu-Jitsu I always take my pants off and
the underwear and I dry and I wipe my
ass then I put my shorts on that's how
[__] particular I am about that I
never go in that [__] thing with
rotten ass
yesterday it was so hot that I actually
went in there my t-shirt was still wet
and it was a brand new t-shirt it was
amazing so today I took it to get clean
and I washed it and I hand washed it and
the whole thing and I'm looking at the
[__] car and I'm like how many
[__] birds of [__] in this thing you
know right that's it I got to turn it in
anyway my wife's got to turn her in my
wife's going to [__] kill me with
that lease so doesn't really matter but
the point of situation is
uh you have a nice car yeah tell them
what you drive I have Volkswagen jeda
okay some people are sitting there going
VW [__] you Lee it's a cheap car hey
[__] you that car
Sparkles so here's Lee pulling up with
his little VW now Lee could have been an
[__] Lee could have been uh what's
the word people use when you're a
[__] fake
[__] you could have gone and got lattes
all right from Starbucks and you know
because I love this tea from Africa and
you know what it's funny someone when I
went in asked me are those from
sprinkles like the cupcake place that
it's $20 for yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah [__] you and sprinkles these are
handmade from some badass Mexican
[__] that don't [__] around oh
yeah it's amazing but you know what Lee
you set your mark and you enforced it
you went in there with the donuts you
believed that were good you had your
suit on you walk in there with
confidence it was just a couple things
that gave you that conf listen just
because you don't have confidence or you
don't think you have confidence there's
things you could
do that get you so excited that the
confidence comes naturally did you
notice that yesterday oh yeah yeah like
as soon as they got excited there you go
and when I say I don't have any
confidence I'm misspeaking I think if
you listen to episode number one of
this that would be more nobody has
confidence every you have it seems like
you do when I was a kid I was half
effect I hit in the head with a lunch
box to changed me for who I am PTSD in
full effect you know what I'm saying if
anybody got PTSD as me hit that lunchbox
hit me and changed me forever I started
eating meat and [__] and chicken
delivered before I was a half a [__]
up kid man my dad died so but confidence
sometimes is a new pair of shoes yeah is
your shirt
ironed is
your hair
trimmed my [__] fingers are [__]
disgusting next week we're both going
for [__]
manicures I can't finger bang
confidently I looked at my fingers about
two weeks ago I'm like who would let me
finger these I don't have fungi nail I
don't have the Mickey Rook fingers the
Fingers of Death you ever see Mickey
rook's fingernails no he's got what I
got on my toe on his fingernail oh no
he's got fungi nail on his toes on his
hands that's not good I have just
[__] fingernails that you know I've
had chamy these finger every this
fingernail had the herp this one had
this one had [__] each one is a
different oh please I this these fat gun
hands are disgusting I looked at them
the other day my hands are still soft
you know I put cream on them and [__]
but look at these you know you can't get
a nice job with dirty F my fingers are
not dirty people my cuticles are out
they're not uh what do you call that
when you polish them whatever when you
put the [__] thing on them you know
you file them this [__] more
I don't know what that looking at me did
anyone else know what that meant sure
you listen you want a job making 60 100
Grand you can't walk in there with dirty
[__] hands there's little things that
different people look at there's nothing
that grosses me up more than finger long
finger you finger everybody has their
own private Idaho long fingernail why
take the chance if let's pretend I don't
give a [__] of your shoes clown shoes
but your hands better be sharp I had a
friend told me that he wouldn't hire
anybody unless they had a watch how's
that one for you that's [__] up I
don't care I don't wear a watch he was a
[__] general manager of an accounting
firm in Jersey I knew this guy forever
talked to him to about eight years ago
he married he moved to [__] nck it's
over but he told me at every [__] he
goes I've never been every one of his
employees lasted over 20 years because
he always made sure they had a watch if
somebody came into an interview without
a watch he would not hire him how
[__] that's racism that's prejudism
you don't even know I've never I've had
watches I just can't put them on I was
looking at a watch I had the other day
it's so many little things when you're
trying to look for a job but guess what
Lee anything beats sitting there and
pressing that button and really thinking
that somebody's going to contact you now
a lot of people at home going jooy
you're completely wrong I got a job
offline I didn't say that I'm just
saying I'm upping your rods a little bit
if I see a [__]
job that I really
want do you have any
idea you get excited about it oh my god
when I was a kid I'd look at that paper
every day I was one of those people I
had a job and after about a week I'm
like there's got to be something better
maybe I'll be a dry
waller and I would quit this now we get
an apprenticeship with a drywall company
30 days 8 bucks an hour after that you
go up to 12 of you know I knew how to
[__] rap these people cuz people
always want to teach okay so that's how
I would always get a job in
construction cuz people people like
teaching their crap I set them up I
don't least say had Joey Diaz
listen I really want to be uh I'm
looking for the job as a hard carrier
have you ever been a hard carrier before
not really but my father's uncle was a
hot carrier and he told me what I had to
do I had to mix sand 16 Scoops and to
each bag of concrete I got to have your
brick ready for you uh why do you want
to be a hotti Lee you're going to school
you know what I really don't want to go
to school I like brick I've always been
interested in Brick and everybody says
you're the best you're the best brick
mason so let's make a deal let's do this
instead of paying me 10 pay me eight and
teach me your course teach me what you
know eight out of 10 people hire you
because you just paid them a tremendous
compliment you told them they were the
best and you wanted to learn from them
that person's going to hire you even if
you don't know if you've never heard
about this guy before and even if they
don't hire you maybe they'll tell
someone else yeah like that's a big
thing like people say connections I
think it's just you meet people guys I
was in San Francisco I had no [__] I
walked into a biggest Mexican restaurant
looking for a bartend the job the guy
gave it to the sheet to another guy the
guy looked at it he took me aside he
goes you know my name is Jose Diaz and
I'm Cuban too and we started talking he
goes if you want to wait a couple weeks
I'll give you a job job but I get your
job right now right now go to rock and
Robins on hate ashberry boom I got a
[__] job you know what time I walked
into that place that morning what time
7:59 I knew it opened at 11: but in
those days it didn't matter if the
[__] place opened at 11: or 12 I made
myself leave the house at
7:30 that's all the other part of
leaving of getting a job there are so
many [__] aspects that you have to do
and that's the number one on [__] any
list that you see you either got to a be
up early and get a jump on the morning
or be get the [__] out of the house both
of those are the most important thing in
your [__] day and then you ask Trump
you ask anybody who's made Fortunes in
this [__] nobody Sleeps past [__]
6 they want to be up they want to be
alive they want to be kicking not only
that you want to be moving at 8:00 I
want to be I want to ask you a [__]
history question and I expect you to
[__] say the whole thing boun but
bound 1696 that's how clearheaded you
are because even if you're not you have
to make yourself
thatly so it has nothing to do with like
the them or the other people getting
being their first you just for you you
want to be at attention as you say like
right away it's all the whole thing
that's what you don't have confidence
get up at six you'll have
confidence you'll have confidence
because you'll talk yourself into the
confidence by the time you walk into the
guy's [__] office at 10:00 the ask
him for a job or her for a job
everything man
everything is based on
enthusiasm I could tell when I'm
enthusiastic about a set or I could tell
when you saw at the comedy store last
Tuesday when I died death I didn't want
to be there I was half dead on Tuesdays
I'm still [__]
dead and you can't suck yourself up into
it sometimes you can you know me 9 and a
half out of 10 times I psych myself up
to going through the mouth of the
[__] the lion I don't give a [__] but
that was that one percentage that
night it is like and then for those
people who like don't want to get out of
bed or whatever that's it's tough then
it's even harder listen there's a big
there's a a
word that I always have in the back of
my
mind you know you you grow
up I have a daughter I look at my
daughter I see that girl from Marie
Etc okay she's 16 whatever the [__] she
is not the best looking kid in the world
but a heart of gold she was goofing with
us the other day my wife made a [__]
remark cuz that's how my wife is and
Becky giggled whatever I didn't think it
was funny cuz I thought of her as my
daughter anyway I go over to Jiu-Jitsu
There She is again she's the [__]
waitress over there these are these kids
that are [__] working you know I'm so
high I forgot my point Lisa the wa the
waitress at
no I know I know like you know oh not
wanting to get out of bed not wanting to
get out of bed now you see a kid like
this at this kid's 16 17 she got two
[__] job she knows the way of the
world I don't know what her parents do
but the parents are preparing her and
they made her take a bus I saw her get
off the Magnolia bus okay that means she
goes right from
Marie straight to [__] uh victory in
Magnolia you know what I'm saying on the
way to Flappers right yeah that's the
education of a lifetime for that child
that child's going to be independent do
I have the balls to do that with with
Mercy not in a million [__] years I
think she'll have a job at 15 16 listen
no no you're not getting the point okay
do I have the [__] do I want to be on
Victory and get out into my car and see
mercy and getting out of a [__] bus
at 15 16 not in a million years but
guess what for her to succeed in this
life she has to do those little things
at that age that gives College a better
taste that gives so many [__] things
a better taste you know like it tastes a
lot better if you have your own money at
that time I was a mischievous kid but I
was moving around at 16 Jack and when I
mean moving around I was moving around I
was taking buses into the city I was
going on the bus with Greg herenda the
Five Star Basketball Camp you know in
the eighth grade in the eighth grade we
took a bus to see the New Jersey Nets in
Piscataway we had to take a bus to New
York first then get a connecting bus to
[__] piscato I knew my way around
there when I was a sophomore high when I
was a freshman in high school we'd all
take buses down the
shore 16 of us I knew how to get my way
around you know I want my daughter to
have the same tonight she was
threatening to leave so she took my
computer bag yeah she took my computer
bag she filled it up with t-shirts I
asked her if she had tickets I gave her
a dollar bill and when I left she was
sitting waiting for the bus on the
balcony with my
wife my wife actually got depressed I'm
like she's [__] it's a game Terry
what kids always do I ran away a
thousand times Oreos she was running
away she had no food who's picking you
up she made up some name Kristen's
picking me up okay my cousin Kristen's
picking
up you uh I don't understand what I'm
seeing more and more what I hear more
and more Hey listen the other thing is
there's not that many jobs
guys no especially cuz you said lowering
your well listen there's people who are
taking lower jobs in the there's a lot
of kids that come out of college and
they're very sharp I don't know what the
percentage is that they already have you
know built.com companies coming out of
college or whatever they figured out a
way to make a living there's a lot of
people that have to get a job first to
figure out what the [__] they want to do
you know because just because you get a
job to be a [__] editor don't mean
you want to be an editor when you got
out this ain't way you know you still
like editing and stuff and you're still
very good at it but it's different than
what you thought or what whatever it
doesn't matter right and and I thought I
knew what I wanted to do I thought I did
turned out not not to be the case but
how many [__] kids you think that
happens I think it happens to a lot of
kids who had like they just quit like if
I had met you I probably would be
editing and I'd be
happyish but it's uh I think a lot of
people who would will go and just
abandon what they want and got their
major and like there's people now who
went to law school who aren't going to
be lawyers Paula says like they'll just
they'll be like a professor or something
else which is great for them I guess but
I can't
imagine putting all that work and time
and money in and just abandoning
it so wait a second yeah you could go to
law school not take the bar uh-huh yeah
and just learn all that information yeah
you have a degree but it just it's not
you don't have to get registered as a
lawyer I never [__] knew that you
should go I mean not exactly you have
the time
but yeah there's a lot of people who do
that apparently it would take me six
years to get my law degree and by that
time I'm 59 I can't be a conly lady to a
crime family why not there's it an age
limit well by that time you're out of
the [__] system you know what I'm
saying you don't know what the [__]
going on
so I don't know what the [__] to tell
you Le these stars are all right but the
reef is better let me give some shout
outs here unbelievable Tuesday night
we're here we're hanging out Lisa at
just regular conversation to guys you
know I love to be filled in on what goes
on I don't know what goes on and I know
that you know I know those are my
strengths is getting a [__] job I've
always been able to [__] put one
together doing something Bruce McKenna
Anthony Kelly Ben Grimes Eric Portwood
Ryan Jacobs Brendan baham Matt Mo and as
always my main man Dave
christianen him and Pugsley up in north
in uh
Canada no uh what were you saying I
don't even know what the [__] you're
talking about oh no that's just the the
guy you gave the shout out to
um I I think my lack of confidence
though it will go in different ways like
when I went when I went to college it
freaked me out that people would knock
on your door I don't like that
like I don't like I'm not a very social
person I don't know I think it all I
don't know
man I like people KN on my daugh you
don't like it either no sometimes I
don't even move I just sit there it
depends it depends what point of your
life you're in well I don't even like
friends I don't like friends dropping by
gives me I don't
know it's uh you you said told me a
couple months ago that like you noticed
that I I I live alone and it's true it's
it's absolutely true I I it's not that I
don't like people but
I you pay the premium to have your space
some people have listen some people when
you're young you're 20 you're like yeah
sure what the [__] I live with Lee for
[__] 8250 a month and Joey and all
you go take a [__] and there's three
[__] shits in there before you
nobody's flush the toilet the shower a
mess you go get that steak sandwich you
brought home it's gone the kitchen's got
mice in it the living room has beer can
you know you everybody establishes that
one relationship we've all had it and
you last either a week or a year I think
I lasted like two [__] weeks then I
had a decent roommate for a while that
there was always kitchen was clean that
was great I could have still been living
with them cuz we laughed our asses off
every night and we smoked dope and we
both watch the same stupid movies and
and then at the end of night he had a
girlfriend that come he' go into one
room at that time I didn't have a
girlfriend I go into the listen to them
[__] I bang one out and I'd go to
sleep that's
it no but then there's but if it wasn't
him I couldn't have somebody else I knew
how I am I know the type of person I am
even my wife creeps up on me from time
to time it drives me [__]
crazy
but my issue isn't isn't really with
like it is sometime sometimes with that
but then I I I do something that's
really I don't think I've have ever told
anyone like when I if I if I leave a
room and I close a door I sit there I'm
like like what are they going to say
about me like that's always my main
mentality you been in the house by
yourself not not in the house by myself
this has Happening by yourself what's
going on with you I wake up this morning
the sprinklers on your face are you
[__] losing it over here these Stars
killing you you need another star anyway
you look are they killing you let me get
you another one yeah let me get you
another one you're looking light tonight
you oh my God what what did I have
seven mad I'm many had how many a gun to
had get a master disaster Lisa yeah
you're the master disaster Lisa yeah
there you go no I don't do it at the
house
alone like if I leave like a a room with
people in
it a room with people yeah like if I
leave kettle bells okay I'll wait
outside the door and I'm like I just
close the door and I expect to hear them
saying like he was terrible uh the worst
I hate him like I just I don't know what
it
is my brain is crazy I'm really well I
think they say that naturally anyway
yeah I walk around I'm like oh these
people [__] don't like me but who
gives a [__] that's not the confidence
thing that's
just maybe an insecurity thing which I
have also I know exactly how it feels to
walk around I just don't put my ear to
the door and go are they saying
something I don't put my ear but like
I'll sit there for like 10 seconds just
be like okay no okay
you're a young
man you work hard you sleep you're not a
Criminal by any means you
know I mean you know [__] Clark Gable
you know what's the got what's the guy
who crashed in the Fast and the Furious
oh um I mean you know Paul Walker Paul
Walker yeah you know you know Elvis
Presley I mean but you're a handsome
little fellow you know what I'm saying
thank you sir a girl call me cute in my
building today that's right you're a
little cute little [__] little dude
so um you have no reason to not be
confident you know even if you had one
eye you got to be confident have you
ever seen
anybody that you look at and they have
like something physical like myself with
the scars or you see another girl like
with the red thing on their eyes the the
pink on their eyes or you see somebody
who's maybe missing a few fingers have
you ever seen that confidence bro I live
next to a girl with no legs and she our
elevator went out for a couple weeks
they put her in a hotel but I saw her
one day when she came back she pushed
herself up three flights of
stairs she's she's
amazing and the confidence when she
walks up to you yeah uh sh shoulders up
shoulders back you don't
know you can't really believe that she's
doing that you know what I'm saying like
you can't really believe that she has
that confidence with with what is going
on in her life I've always looked at
those people and said why is that
beautiful girl able to walk around with
that scar on her face with it like if
it's not on their
face and that's the beauty I hate when I
see somebody who's
overweight that you could see is [__]
dead like they're sad inside you ever
see them they're looking down they like
[__] mopes you know they're stuck
they're they're going home at night they
can't stop eating Ramen or they can't
stop eating something that's really
unhealthy for them you know it's it like
goes back to the clothing thing when
you're that big and all you're wearing
is gym shorts and t-shirts you're like
ah what the oh my God just it's just a
horrible
feeling and then the dawn on you you
know like we talked about change like
with the comedy change is the toughest
[__] thing because we think that we
might get on to something you know Le if
I go to the gym once a
week I don't know what do you
think oh well maybe you might meet
somebody ice no I'm talking about what
could happen for my you know like that's
how it starts and all a sudden you go
there and you can't believe that this
thing changed you in the way like comedy
changed me took 25 [__] years took 15
years but it changed me it got me
married it got my my life back together
it got me another chance of being a
dad you know comedy did all that I stuck
it out with it you got to stick it out
with
[__] you know you everybody it's it
doesn't come like just like that it
comes over time and it gets hard there's
there's bumps and there's valleys
whatever the [__] but you go through
them and that's what all of a sudden
you're there you've arrived where you
wanted to be but I wish it happened
listen I wish we had millions of [__]
downloads people in India listening to
us you know whatever the [__] it is but
you know what that's not the way it is
and I'm not angry at I'm very fortunate
four people listen to us I knew this
going in but we stuck with it you know I
got a call from two people yesterday hey
I want you to come on my new podcast new
podcast how many [__] podcast you
got right yeah everybody's got a new
[__] podcast for a few weeks it's
tough yeah and and it's like Lee and I
have banged it out over whatever time
listen today I almost didn't do this
podcast L really at 5:30 I wasn't
feeling you've never you've never I
don't think you've ever once done that
it's almost 400 episodes why do you do
that or I didn't feel good this
morning last night was one of the
weirdest nights I've had in a long
[__] time in what way
it was hot yesterday guys real hot and
in the daytime I moved around a lot and
there was a period there where I
couldn't stop
sweating like I was outside and stuff I
went in I took a shower cold water put
new clothes on bam that was fine then I
went into the bathroom and oh my God Lee
I thought I was going to die in the saw
it oh cuz the bathroom was so I was in
there taking a dump I didn't want to say
that but I'm in there [__] in 6 seven
minutes I'm like
Jesus I don't like opening up the door
the door is
three
so then I go outside to do a a joint
thing a periscope and again I me it's
blazing out there guys phone almost
melted so I go inside blah blah blah
blah blah my wife goes to bed first she
pops out a lot lat and says I can't
sleep in there it's just too warm and
I'm like let me go in there and recheck
it out sure enough to window those 3 in
up I close that I close the curtains I
point the [__] things towards the bed
I pour the blanket down I pour the
[__] blanket down there's no blanket
tonight it's going to be a sheet she
goes I'm just going to sleep in the
baby's room done I went in there and I
hit the crib at about [__] A quar to
11 Jack bam don't even remember falling
asleep I wake up around
3 and I walk and it's not hot
but it's not quite cold yet it's cool
nobody's sweating but it's not what I'm
used to you know what I'm saying at 3:
in the morning so I go out I
pee and right away I just don't feel
right not like I'm in a faint or not
like I'm going to die or nothing like
that something I try to tap into the
cats they're sleeping I thought it was
the cats I thought the cats were out
their earring at each other they're
[__] sleeping so I'm like what is
this [__] weird feeling out here so I
finally puted the robe on I went outside
I drank some
water after a few minutes I went outside
I smoked a few
balls right it had to be 3:30 in the
morning I'm out there coughing sparking
like a
Savage I go back in I turn the TV on
don't ask me what was on dog I go back
in there at 400 in the morning it's
freezing the air conditioner was at full
blast I know how to maneuver the air
conditioner my wife don't know how to
[__] around with it there's ways to do
different things I've been working air
conditioners all my
life yeah that's why I need the central
air I slept straight till 7:30 got up
had a smoothie walked her did a few
things and I just couldn't take it no
more I was tired man I just didn't feel
good hit the crib got up did some few
things again went back and actually fell
asleep again till
4:45 so something's going on either I'm
sick or something's not right I had a
little rash the other day maybe it's
ringor who the [__] knows what it is Ain
no [__] ring worm uh I don't even
know what to tell you that's [__] up
it's so I was tired the point being that
I got up I had no appetite I went
outside I smoked a little bit then I got
a little appetite I
ate and then after that I said you know
what I can't can't cuz tomorrow there's
no way I can't fit it in nowhere I'm
from coast to coast my day starts
tomorrow at [__] 9:30 Jack I got some
stupid conference call and I'm the
change Jiu-Jitsu drill Boom come back I
got to a [__] haircut then from there
I had to cancel a [__]
dinner so I'm going to go see a thing at
6 6:00 to 700 like let's shoot to The
Improv and do the living room show at
the [__]
uh where they don't serve Boos whatever
that is the lab the lab do they serve
Boos or they don't I've never been there
what the [__] where you been I don't
know they closed it for a while okay you
never went there to see this is not
happening taping well by the time I uh
got to see this is not happening it was
in the big room it was in the big room
already yeah so that's what I got to do
so I have no time then tomorrow
night
Philly here I come Rose pork maybe what
a roast pork sandwich no I don't know I
don't know what I'm going to eat you got
you got a plan man what I don't know
what time I
neighborhood I don't know what hotel I'm
going to stay at I'm not worried about
it Le I'm really not worried about it I
don't want no I don't want nothing would
you eat roast pork if you got five sold
out shelves why take the chance you need
the you fall energy no the pork ain't
going to give me no energy what if that
pork is rotten and I can't do those five
shows do you follow I'm saying to you
there's no fish the first night there's
none of that you e very lean the first
night I'll make a protein Shake I I'll
make my wife make like chicken cutlets
I'll take a few chicken cutlets with me
I'll drink some water at the hotel just
to get my bacterials going for the for
the [__] you pack chicken cets
sometimes for the flight you got to pull
out a chicken cutet from time to time to
throw people off you that sucks you
can't put ketchup on it you can't bring
ketchup and they really think you're
[__]
crazy yeah tomorrow night they'll make
chicken cets or mashed potatoes I'll eat
a few for breakfast bring two on the
plant play with me I want to be
around oh yeah I'm a chicken CET type of
[__] they always brighten my day
now that gives me confidence a nice
chicken cutlet cold you put some salt
and pepper on it little ketchup and just
eat it walking around nobody knows
what's going on ketchup oh my God and
you shmear it with the fork into little
valleys and the chicken cutlet who the
[__] you think you're dealing with Le
you want to go eat [__] that that
can't be allowed kind need a for all the
rules you have you can't be smearing
ketchup on chicken tremendous it's a
light shmear I don't dope it up that's
too much sugar you just give it a light
smear just to throw the chicken off for
years you've been eating that [__] mixed
with mayonnaise and Burger King and all
those other places I don't mix the
mayonnaise with the ketchup ketchup goes
straight on [__] even when I do make
the mayonnaise sandwich I put mayonnaise
and I Sav the ketchup you never mix
mayonnaise and ketchup that's McDonald's
and all those [__] chains that's how
you add that's how you make the meat
sauce you didn't know that why can't you
mix it though because that's for Animals
you don't want to mix mayonnaise and
[__] ketchup and put on your
cheeseburger I told you that I was
putting Mayas on my burger and I told my
mom and both of you yelled at me oh yeah
because you're a Savage that's why you
poison your dad he's probably coming
with his canteen he's ready to go down
and
[__] no one got poisoned no nobody puts
mayonnaise on their burgers they do the
Wendy's that's right because they're
[__] idiots that who would eat a
burger at [__] Wendy and get sick you
would I know I've never once
gotten you do you you don't know it you
don't [__] know what happens those
things sit in your stomach and they
start eating away your bacteria and
little by little you got little Pebbles
down there and [__] and then you got to
shave your head and walk around and hang
out with weird people keep it
up those days r with we you're a new
[__] man you're throwing kettle
bells you're looking good you got a
little sun to you I'm still burnt from
like a month ago I know you got to go
out that's when you went on the [__]
Ferris wheel right no no it's when I
went to the beach oh that's right you
went to the beach too like you had time
to be at the beach Johnny muscles over
here what beach did you go to point and
doom and what what kind of bikini did
you put on a regular just a a long
bathing suit a long ba like goes past
the knees I don't wear I am going to if
if I get down to like 150 I am going to
wear a Speedo did you put suntown lotion
on every hour I put on them before we
left I put on when we got there and then
every hour jump in the water I did at
one point I I I made a point of it I I
didn't dunk my head I couldn't it was
too cool you got to jump in the water
I'm not mad at you cuz you jumped in the
water you got to jump in the [__]
water that one's scary though I don't
even know a mosquito Bay is I just know
where the Doom Point Doom yeah all right
I know not listen we ate eight stars
tonight that's Point Doom some beach
could suck my dick you want to Point
Doom com on over there's eight [__]
stars take a chance Columbus did [__]
what's up Lis say what do you got
planned this weekend with the old man U
my yeah my dad's coming um I think we go
get a stake and then we like want a
cigar like lounges like place with like
sit in leather chair and smoke a cigar
you what a steak Yeah we you taking them
for a steak I don't know maybe Morton's
all right now where you going I don't
know where but I just know that only
approved your list no take them for
lunch it's 22 yeah no that's a good idea
you get to get the dessert to get the
little potato you get a little [__]
salad and you look like a hero for 22
bucks right or wrong that's the that's
the lunch
special the power of one special you
tomorrow you're going to go over to
[__] perennial you're going to sign
up you going tell them my sense you're
going to go in the back and you're going
to get you're going to pay a little
extra but but think of how many [__]
Edibles we get dropped on this every
once in a while you got to give a little
back you go over there the perennial and
try something no forget that go to that
[__] place and get cushy cushy Mars
okay just drop a yard stick tomorrow on
cushy month that'll last you all five
days the [__] 200s killed
us right yeah and they have the 50s so
you could buy a couple for him then put
another yard stick and let him take some
to go we mail them for mean I'm we'll
get the [__] we'll get the mule on it
the good plan it's going to cost you
some of them so you might as well go to
the kushim m and get the best out [__]
the white Chu that's 35 for 500 migr oh
no no no no cushy Mart go over to Sunset
herbal tell them Uncle Joey sent you bam
get yourself a [__] cushy thing the
two the 200 milligram it tastes like
[__] dick but it takes you to the
next level I ain't going to lie to
nobody and then they have the other
sizes and the other sizes taste good
they're fruer oh I've never tried those
sizes you get the make sure you get a
200 cuz you're in training don't let me
find out I'll make them go on a computer
you know I got the girls the records
yeah I got the girls on the record over
there but uh you need to get the fruity
ones for your dad they got 50s and 25s
and get them a che butu you know spend a
yard or two what you going to do with
all that money what happens if you if I
hit you in the head tomorrow with a
chair you die we going to leave all
those Millions to under the m
some [__] half a ju fund or something
sure yeah that's the one the half a
fund stop who you going to leave all
those Millions you got to Wolf Gang Puck
Wolf Gang Puck that [__]
Nazi that
[__] I'm tired
guys I don't know what to tell you guys
I'm just uh trying to rest
up before Philadelphia how cool is
Philly going to be Philly is going to be
cool but there 250 animals per show Le
these people are [__] animals I love
them I love him with all my heart
Philly's great but it's it's 50 minutes
of duke it out you up there throwing
[__] punches my
friend it's a struggle five days it's a
real
City it's a real City you can't go up
there no throw no Okie do jokes and [__]
and I me it's it's a big deal I mean
this is the first time like that you
sold out like a week or two in advance
it's great I know they're great
Philadelphia is a great City man I grew
up in [__] Philadelphia they know the
deal they feel it in my [__] heart
don't take much they hear me they
[__] hear me I'm one of their
uncles everybody in their family in
Philadelphia got a crazy uncle like me
that don't do anything in the world he's
just a little [__]
crazy you don't have a crazy uncle you
that's
it no oh my my family's pretty white
they're pretty [__] straight
yeah let's smoke some more reefa and
then we'll let your [__] go
home to your own thing tonight tonight
was just a mild little podcast two guys
just talking talking about what's going
on in life what's affecting him what's
affecting
me I'm getting old man you
uh my [__] right eye is
done it's done I keep catching myself on
the left side it's
I'm having a hard time reading the TV
from far away the whole [__] thing so
I'm not sweating it just go hey you do
Coke for 27 years shit's going to break
apart you know what I'm saying can you
get lay sick or something I don't know
already say he didn't work I don't
[__] know what's going on my dad got
it he said he likes
it you know you're supposed to smoke
reefer they say if you smoke reefer you
got 2020 Vision that [__] ain't working
for me you know what I'm saying I've
never read that yeah I heard that for
years no glowcoma 2020 Vision everybody
else [__] walking around with [__]
binoculars in their eyeballs me I can't
see out of my right [__] eyes so I
don't get it Lee you got those sheets
for me my
brother nice nice conversation you
brought up tonight I know you got a lot
of questions you're a man with a lot of
questions yes I
am and that's what I [__] love about
you you understand me Club w Club W is
the Revolutionary wine club that
delivers high quality wine straight to
your door they partner with Innovative
wine makers from all over the world to
produce a wide variety of small lot
handcrafted wines for their members okay
with Club W you have the freedom to pick
and choose the types of wines and the
number of bottles you receive each month
the best part is they offer 100%
satisfaction guarantee on every single
bottle start drink drinking personalized
wine selections today try Club
W have you been in a wine now you're
walking around at your local store and
you're staring at this massive selection
of wine with no idea which bottle to
choose most of us go with a bottle that
has the best looking label and hope
that's going to be good well the days of
playing Russian roulette with your wine
selection are done Club W is a
revolutionary new wine club that takes
the guesswork out of choosing your wine
they got a simple six question palet
quiz that will match you with delicious
high quality wine your Garin teed to
love delivered right to your door what
makes them different they deliver it to
your door they send the wine that is
personally to your pet taste and we work
with top wine makers and Growers from
around the world directly to make our
own wine our $13 bottles would normally
retail for $20 this is what right now
when I'm I'm doing to my listeners all
right right now Club W is offering $20
off your first order when you go to Club
w.com Joey again it gets even better I
know you hate paying for shipping so
Club W will actually pay for your
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more so take something off your to-do
list just go to
club.com Joey to get $20 off your first
order of wine all right this is your
fourth of July deal right now that's
Club
w.com Joey how's that for you Le I
bounce back from the death of catacombs
if you're watching live I'm sorry you
know what I'm
saying things happen I got a phone you
got a phone you got a call you know your
day goes here there you misplaced stuff
Smart Cars Smart phones Smart Homes
Technology has made everything smart but
losing your stuff still makes Smart
people feel really stupid all right
Traer tracker makes losing things a
thing of the past all right tracker
makes losing things a thing of the past
track is a coin-size device that locates
misplaced Keys wallets bags computers
anything in
seconds just bear track it to the
smartphone attach it to anything and
find its precise location with the tap
of a button it's that easy lose your
phone press the button on track and your
phone rings even when it's on island
with over 1.5 million devices tracker
has the largest crowd GPS Network in the
world so your lost item show up on a map
even if it's miles away so do me a favor
never lose anything again with tracker
listeners of the show get a special 30%
off your entire order again 30% off your
entire order go to the th H tracker.com
and at the promo code Church CH H ch the
hardest thing you'll ever have to find
is their website all right again go to
the tracker.com right now and then the
promo code church for 30% off your
entire
order like I said you'll never lose
anything again all right again that's
the
tracker.com promo code church
church Lee don't sit there so
enthusiastic [__] you know what
I'm saying again we were talking about
confidence and what people need to do
and what the people need not to do let
me tell you something where confidence
really starts with your [__]
underwear sometimes you know what I get
sweaty underwear and I feel [__]
dirty you go out and talk to people you
switch in the dirt you don't wash your
ass you put the same underwear on that's
disgusting okay and that stuff it just
wears and tears your underwear when you
save when you wear the same underwear
yeah you save on laundry detergent but
you're blowing out that [__] back
section with the smell of your ass and
funguses and God knows what you got back
there I don't even tell you what I got
back back there but anyway whether
you're wearing a suit or sweats you
spend 24 hours a day and you're
underwear but instead of making a
statement like Superman's tights under
the everyday clothes your underwear is
probably you know boring well guess what
meundies is here to change that every
pair of meundies is made from
substantially sourced modor a fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton again
mold is pronounced mold nothing can
describe the FIT of meundies but once
you try them you'll understand why they
call the world's most comfortable
underwear and even if you don't love
your first pair of meundies they're free
no questions asked meundies has dozens
of styles and limited addition prints to
help you make statement with your
underwear whether anyone can see them or
not remember Superman all right listen
Mund is are comfortable as [__] I wear
them under every ghee I wear him to
Jiu-Jitsu I wear them when I swing
kettle bells you know why it keeps
everything dry trust me when I tell you
this so do me a favor as part of my
little deal with you guys shipping is
free in the US and Canada and you save
up to $8 a pair with the m Mundi
subscription plan how about that get the
subscription or a single pair and get
20% off your first order when you go to
meundies.com jooy that's meundies.com
joeey for 20% off your first order again
me undies.com
joeey thank you for listening again on
it Club W tracker and meundies that's
all I got to tell you [__] like
I said I'm having surgery and after that
the little mini tour starts so I'm going
to be at all these places July 21st
Flappers which is the back room it only
seats 50 if you want to come out it's a
nice little time you see me doing the
special from the beginning and working
August 4th to Flappers August 31st at
the Ice House September 8th at Flappers
September 28th at the Ice House October
4th at The Comedy Store and October 11th
at The Comedy Store so take a chance
Columbus did [__] come on out Lis IAD
thank you very much for another fun Phil
week you're always a gentleman and a
pleasure to work with thank you sir and
I hope you have a good time in Philly
absolutely it's going to be [__]
great they're going to miss you and [__]
they know you to go over there and eat
yourself to death oh yeah next time next
time I'm not going to let that happen
you know
I'm and no song birds are
singing when the Twilight is
gone you come into my
[Music]
heart and here in my heart you will stay
while I
[Music]
pray my
prayer is to linger with
you at the end of the
day in a dream that's
[Music]
Divine my
prayer is a Rapture in
blue with the world far
away and your lips close to my
to
not why our hearts are
[Music]
glow oh tell me the
words that I'm Longing To
Know
my
pra and the answer you
[Music]
give may they still be the
same for as long as we
live that you'll always be
[Applause]
there at the end
of
my
[Applause]
[Music]
pray